news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
so during that absolutely stunning
interview with fox news's chris wallace
which we looked at
earlier chris wallace mentions a fox
news poll where biden is ahead of trump
49-41
and the poll actually has a ton of
fascinating data points now as a
reminder
fox news polling and fox news channel
are two different things fox news
polling is actually considered
quite good and and accurate so a few
things as we get into it
this is a poll of registered voters
remember that
the least accurate in terms of
predicting an election is to just
survey all adults more accurate is
registered voters
and then ideal is likely voters although
you tend to see
fewer likely voter polls this early you
see more of those as we get
closer to election day now one other
thing just a short circuit those claims
about oh they only called landlines we
can't trust this
as you can see in the methodology this
was done
with a 237 landline recipients and 867
cell phones so they call cell phones
this was mostly cell phones now on key
issues
super important on the economy
47 to 47 biden and trump
on who is better to handle the economy
the economy has been trump's one issue
lately where he was polling better than
joe biden
last week in the quinnipiac poll joe
biden pulled better than trump on the
economy
in this fox news poll they are tied
that's not good for trump
not surprisingly on race relations trump
is way underwater
only 35 approved 35 approve of trump on
race relations
56 percent disapprove i already
mentioned
biden up 49 to 41 by eight in the
general election poll
right now four percent say they would
vote for other
five percent say they don't know yet and
then now it gets really interesting when
vote uh when a poll recip uh poll uh
poll
what would we call them poll takers uh
subjects were asked about vote by mail
63 of the country says they favor vote
by mail
compared to 28 percent who oppose this
suggests
that trump loudly opposing vote by mail
as he has been doing
may not really be a good strategy to
bring more people over to his side
now this is really important and very
interesting i recently said
if they have debates biden shouldn't go
at trump's insults or wacky behavior
i said there are three primary issues
that have hurt trump
and that should be the focus coronavirus
the economy as a result of coronavirus
and the protest george floyd race issues
when asked what are the most important
issues today
the issues are 29 say coronavirus
15 say the economy jobs and unemployment
and 10 say race relations and police
issues so
those three issues are the top issues
for
54 of the country it's really important
to confirm our hypotheses it appeared
that
coronavirus the economy and race
relations were the most important issues
and the ones that have hurt trump the
most
and indeed it appears that that is the
case now last thing
there was a question about mental
soundness for years we've been seeing
concerning signs from trump about his
cognitive state
there's also a joe biden has dementia
movement i've admitted biden has
definitely slowed down
from where he was in his 60s despite it
not appearing to be dementia according
to every mental health expert i've
spoken to
the poll asked do you think biden and
trump have the mental soundness to serve
effectively as president 47 believe
biden has the mental soundness
only 43 percent believe trump does now
those numbers are just really low the
fact that
neither candidate has half the country
believing they are mentally sound
is a problem but note that fourteen
percent
aren't sure about biden seven percent
aren't sure about
trump the important takeaway is more
people
question trump's fitness for office than
bidens
although not by a huge margin so the big
takeaways here
are our instinct about what matters this
election
has been right the polls are
consistently showing similar results
and we all have to assume nothing
and vote like our state depends on our
vote
to choose between trump and biden that's
how we should imagine
we are going to uh act on uh on november
3rd or before if you're voting early and
i hope many of you do
my vote could swing my state from trump
to biden
i'm sure as hell voting in that case
let's take a quick break make sure
you're following me on instagram
david.pakman we will be right back